today today it's just one of those
[ __ ] days name its this I'm I'm tired
I'm really tired
wow what a problem I'm sure you have the
only one in the entire world PewDiePie
now I know I trust me I know and I know
these rent videos have been just a
little bit too far in between alright
and I'm sorry I don't mean to make this
a habit pirate is not the right word I'm
struggling I'm [ __ ] struggling is
what I'm trying to say I'm having a deep
[ __ ] issue let me try and explain this
in the this is so [ __ ] Randy this
video this is gonna be so ready ahh
last year 2016 October worst month of my
life I'm pretty sure at least I I think
I went insane I think I went crazy it
probably didn't show on camera like it
is right now
I lost my mind I went crazy because I
had too much stuff to do and usually I'm
pretty good at taking it but then it
just went overboard and I I literally I
think I hit the ball I hit the ball
pretty hard and I Oh boohoo it's hard
it's hard for you I get it but this year
I'm just really conscious about getting
too much work on me and I'm pretty sure
I'm getting close to that limit again
and I'm scared that I'm gonna hit the
wall again where I'm just gonna [ __ ]
lose my mind again and you know I work
all day on a video and people just
[ __ ] hate it and I can't help but
feeling a little bit personal invested
alright usually I'm pretty far ahead
with the content so I don't really give
a [ __ ] it's like oh yeah that video I
made that two days ago I don't give a
[ __ ] but now it's like I'm behind so I
feel so like I have all this buildup of
this video and I want to share it but
all I get is like where's Resident Evil
7 Beauty path and I'm like [ __ ]
I made this for you
this video I put all this time and
effort into it cuz my strategy has
lately been to just make videos that are
as good as they can be ignore this 1 in
but now that resonable comes out it's
like it's [ __ ] hard to keep up like
I'm struggling like crazy and only is it
like apparently every youtuber on the
planet is playing Resident Evil 7 right
now and it's just like [ __ ] man how am I
gonna keep up like two years ago you
could upload like 10-minute parts and
you'd be fine now it's like oh you gotta
upload at least an hour otherwise I'm
gonna go watch Toby Turner play this
[ __ ] like it's always like I'm trying to
step everything up and I'm just for me
this is my psychic gift and I need you
guys to just realize that I'm a person
all right I make mistakes I can only do
so much [ __ ] weird last video I
usually have some kind of coherent line
of what I'm gonna say but this is just
[ __ ] by rambling I'm just away
basically I just wanted to let you guys
know that I'm struggling I'm really
struggling right now I gotta work ahead
that's always something in my mind I
always got to work ahead because there's
I have all these other obligations that
I got to do I got TV appearances that
I'm locked in to do I got a travel and
[ __ ] and oh I know so hard for you but
no I just want to make videos that's all
I really care about it's like hey
put-upon you want you want to go for
lunch later
oh no thank you though I don't have time
hey I put you wanna go on this holiday
with me oh yeah please do and I know
everyone's gonna be like uh PewDiePie
why don't you just take a break take a
break relax don't get me wrong I
appreciate that but at the same time if
I want to go on holiday I'll just I'll
just do it I don't want to go on holiday
I just need you guys to understand that
if I make a piece-of-shit video and just
know I tried okay
I know okay here's here I got it I got
it this is this is the explanation I
make self-deprecating jokes on this
channel now I think I started doing that
and you bros and my audience are playing
along with that but sometimes it gets a
little much
sometimes I need you guys to just be
kind of nice about it all right because
I have feelings damn it feel like this
video is some kind of weird celebrity
freak out like I'm fine it's just I'm
feeling very tired
alright I'm literally rendering a video
while I'm recording this one to save
time like I'm so short on time the
problem is I have too many things to do
right now and I'm trying really [ __ ]
hard to juggle everything and when I see
you guys just comment a bunch of [ __ ]
because the video wasn't good enough
even though I spent a shitload of time
trying to make it as good as possible it
hurts alright I feel personally invested
and I'm trying my [ __ ] hardest and
it's like everyone's like oh why is even
my floating videos he doesn't even have
to well I care alright I care and was
like why do you care I don't know I
don't know why I give a [ __ ] I'm not
gonna upload on Mondays anymore but I
used to do that before right now I have
too much [ __ ] to do so I think I'm gonna
have to make the decision that I'm not
uploading on Mondays anymore I know R
isn't an evil it will probably just last
like a week and a half or whatever it's
not a big deal I'm already short on time
and then to do these episodes it's even
even more time I do want to say the
support that I am getting when you kind
of feel like [ __ ] and you have too much
to do when you stress that I really
appreciate that like those when I read a
comment when I really need it it means a
lot and don't don't think I'm just
focusing on all the bad stuff because
I'm I'm not I do want to apologize for
this video for being extremely ranty I
[ __ ] hate when people make rants on
YouTube and Here I am making one I just
didn't know how else to make this one I
just wanted to speak from my heart and
without a script or anything like that
YouTube is really promoting 10-minute
videos it's so obvious like a lot of
people are joking like his channel is
dying but it's like no my channel is
doing better than is ever done because I
started doing like 10 minute videos
because watch time is is king on YouTube
now so you have to make longer videos
but I really feel strongly about keep
making good content even though it's
longer I know a lot of people like oh
look he only makes 10-minute videos now
he only cares about money but it's like
I'm still really trying to make it
good ten minutes not like [ __ ] title
cards for 30 seconds ten minutes you
know and I don't mean to complain I'm
just more speaking honestly how I feel
and I hate it I hate for it to be
considered complaining I don't want to
be just the guy that keeps complaining
or whatever but it's also like a lot of
people have the approach of like Oh put
a pipe makes so much money why does he
complain I hate I hate seeing that it's
almost sad seeing that because he makes
me think like the majority of people
value money more than anything it makes
me think that people think that just
because you have money all your [ __ ]
problems are solved maybe some people
don't care that much about money you
know as long as you get I can afford to
live comfortably I don't give a [ __ ]
about rest like I'm not I don't want to
buy all five Lambos I don't give a [ __ ]
and so just because people it's commonly
known thanks to [ __ ] media by the way
thanks a [ __ ] lot that I make a great
living it's like I'm not allowed to
express my feelings it's [ __ ]
annoying it's [ __ ] I need to get a
haircut leave a comment down below what
haircut I should get top comment will
get pinned and I'll pick it thank you
also be sure to check out my other blogs
[Music]
by here I'm so I'm like genuinely tired
can you tell like